hi my name is Kelly chambers I am an
astrologer I'm about to guess these
wonderful people's Sun signs just based
on some interview questions so we'll see
we'll see how this goes I'm gonna start
with you we're gonna go down the line
what's your name
Aaron Aaron okay tell me about your last
relationship are you in one now I'm not
in you know I'm single how did that one
fall apart and tell me you can also tell
me their sign I don't think I know you
don't know do you believe in astrology I
do yeah okay tell me how that really
ship ended
mainly because of distance so no Babylon
nobody okay do you have lots of lots of
relationships tell me the importance of
kind of relationship in your life I do
like to keep a pretty core group of
people that I'm very close with but I
wouldn't necessarily say I am not
interested in having non core friends
when you were a kid did you take on
responsibility at a young age do you
feel like the older sibling like what
was was there a little bit tell me a
little bit about your I don't know the
mood growing up and kind of your role in
the family I'm the youngest so the
youngest I wouldn't say I took on what
were the things we did as a kid what are
you shy not big into the arts big into
the arts okay how do you feel about
conflict avoid it avoid a I never fight
with anyone okay can you find common
ground with almost anyone and kind of
get along definitely yeah
so Libra Pisces Vermont where my top -
although yeah it's it's a hard call
thank you thank you hi tell me Asian so
tell me a little about your like role in
the family growing up I was kind of
independent like I was like often the
only person and what do you feel about
relationships what do you do go bold and
go in and get really kind of attached in
smoldery or do you find that you kind of
like to keep a distance play it slow
kind of build trust over time I think I
get really tuned
and you get like really emotionally
intense yeah like emotionally invested
in people what would your best friend
what are the qualities that that he or
she would describe you as maybe like
loyal loyal okay
what's your sense if you were like I
mean I pretty much laugh and giggle at
everything you love and you gloat
everything okay that's cool
how important is beauty to you kind of
visual not important not important
you're like are you a hard worker are
you someone who like can focus and you
like to people know he was like
industrious I'm pretty hard-working yeah
what was your last breakup like five
years ago how was that it was long
distance I mean we were like probably
better as friends and are you okay
talking about your feelings is it
something with people I'm close to and
if you're not you kind of tend to keep a
distance
introverted earthy a little bit
protective you get attached but you seem
to kind of distance yourself
relationships those kind of capi but
that's such a hard energy to read thank
you yes hello my name is Ferran so what
is what is like a headlining quality for
you people are like described sparing in
a world a word what would it be I think
my friends would say funny funny okay
tell me another one
blue loyal yeah what are you good at
what do you excel at do you find
yourself be positions of authority sure
yeah okay do you find it hard taking
orders you like following a routine yeah
I like rule structure like rules and
structure it's kind of Cappy
I want to pretend like I'm spontaneous
you want but you're just not really
spontaneous super capricorns they always
put in their sturdiness they're not
really how important is like Beauty the
arts how your room is decorated I don't
have you don't okay it was not more that
Jeana do you speak any languages do you
travel a lot is that a trouble oh I I
don't speak any other languages it's a
nice fun but you don't you don't like
surprises or spontaneity too much no I
think I planned them out tell me about
your relationships you like to start as
friends what's what are you doing really
shitty investment she's an Aquarius
she's an Aquarius okay which that would
be weird if you were a Capricorn
all right it's gonna be it's gonna be
just process of elimination mm-hmm but
thank you all right okay
okay
Wow a weird design that's very important
to you art art the visual of things I
like aesthetics somewhat experimental I
daresay you're willing to take fashioned
a riff don't know if that's no I'm very
conservative pretty separate like sure
but you Reverend yeah right I like to
pretend okay interesting
have you explored a lot you like to get
out of your comfort zone
not so much somebody you're a homebody
extreme homebody extreme homebody ISM
tell me about your relationship
signature are you in one now even are
you in a committed relationship I'm not
not what was the last one about a year
ago and it was pretty toxic it was what
it
yeah yeah and when you get in there and
you get intense are you like extreme
like you better give me your balls I
wouldn't put it that way I mean um when
it feels right I attach pretty quickly
but like when it doesn't I'll be really
distant you don't have a problem
speaking your truth i surprisingly I'm a
pretty reserved person when it comes to
that okay even like my best friend I he
knows like he doesn't know everything
about me I know your private yeah I'm
very very private anyway I'm just
crossing out Libra and putting Scorpio
and Sag up there
sorry tell me the role of kind of art
beauty aesthetics I think I like to do
weird
more than anything weird yeah yeah I
think I've always found it as like a way
to express myself ever since I was young
are you in a relationship I'm not no I
bro I broke off my engagement oh three
months ago and then we lingered very
toxic for a while and then I just cut it
off completely like last week you could
have completely last week okay what was
your favorite thing as a kid I would say
like acting and singing expressive yeah
I was like a big thing for me when I was
younger did you find that you fit into a
group were you you weren't you've always
the always outlier a little bit of okay
I mean what's your relationship with
kind of surprise spontaneity I don't
like surprises
you don't like surprises so everything
you have a best friend I do what would
they say about you a kind of like top
three qualities passionate passionate
okay
sorry but loyal I don't know what else
she would say right she would never be
like you are my best friend yeah we know
we've been best friends for like 25
years what about conflict with you
are you okay happy do you guys to get
into it you kind of do not enjoy it too
much are you secretly kind of like I'm
tough I have grit I can like I feel like
I'll either go into it and go for your
throat or I'll be like you're being
dramatic I'm not bothering like will not
deal with it all right I'll have to just
have to all have to guess okay thank you
thank you do you get in trouble as a kid
no you did not get in trouble another
one we were a conservative kid I think
I'm one of the adults too like me so
interesting now it's because you valued
their maturity you needed validation you
wanted you wanted to be like them you
wanted to be skillful successful what
was that validation that sweet sweet
validation are you in a relationship
okay what's what's her sign she's a
places are you obsessive are you extreme
do you are you kind of more of a
balanced obsessive but probably not
excesses what's the lesson you got upset
fixate on things yeah you fix it on
things and certain things and what's
your follow-through like do you like are
you a completer you a finisher or poor
completely why do you feel about like
emotions sharing your emotions you tend
it like more do you like how are you
with conflict conflict doesn't scare me
I I mean I think everyone tries to avoid
it but I won't back down from it do you
kind of intellectualize your emotions
you don't like to kind of get into it
you like to keep things mellow
I don't electrolyze them too much but I
am not afraid to express them and what
do you feel about like the truth telling
the truth justice I think the things
aren't black and white everything is
very are you spontaneous I feel like I
bifurcate I feel like at work very
structured in artistic practice very
spontaneous I don't think you're a
Scorpio all my hidden tattoos I know
well you got turn a little more skin
maybe you could have gotten you the boat
Scorpio
okay so Erin Pisces
I'm gonna save where is her Rachel Becky
I'm gonna say so I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say Scorpio I don't know
and say Scorpio Farren there's a cat a
cab you might meet the Capricorn I might
I might have to retract Becky's Scorpio
make you the Scorpio
I mean sad cherries are funny sad Libra
Capricorn Capricorn Libra so your guess
was then I was Pisces I'm sure you
thought it was a Capricorn thought I
wasn't Aquarius yeah well I was a Libra
I'm a Sagittarius banana paisius I mean
it's a lot of information the most
surprising
so you're an Aquarius that was the most
surprising to me you have a guess and
then it's like you can find so many
different ways
[Music]